we will move on 617 830 4750 let's see
who we want to talk to next we've got a
bunch of different people the phones are
blowing up Pat we've got nine people on
hold right now but next we will go to
our caller from the 530 area code caller
what's your name and where are you
calling from hi this is Ryan shediac
coming in from Chico California what's
on your mind Ryan thanks David I'm
wondering and I haven't been able to
access the show but if we're looking
back in terms of history happening right
now are we witnessing basically
Watergate to point out a literal
breaking in of the Democratic National
Convention are you saying are you saying
whether the hacking of the DNC is like
Watergate is that what you're saying uh
yeah well it seems if the reports are
true that the Donald Trump campaign is
the one that worked with Russia sort of
authorizing them to do this wouldn't
this be akin to basically Watergate
you're thinking yeah format right listen
we've been covering this extensively and
we still don't know what is true what is
not true and and that's all going to be
determined but I was very clear if it is
true that Donald Trump or associates of
Trump have been in touch with Russian
operatives by some accounts for up to
five years if that is true and if indeed
we have the so called blackmail file
that earlier in the week was was alleged
to exist we have something here that is
of historic proportions there's no doubt
that this would be the political scandal
of a very very long time I don't know
whether Pat Watergate you know Watergate
fine we can compare it to Watergate or
not but we're talking about potentially
one of the biggest political scandals
that I can recall yeah and if there's
collusion going on there it could be
won't considered even worse than
watergate good yeah you were saying uh
well we know Trump [ __ ] bold and you
know we're talking about golden showers
and things like that now so that
that's the part that's the least
credible to me to be perfectly honest
and even my understanding of it would be
that there was the idea of making it
seem as though Trump has this fetish for
a year and I mean I think now we're
getting off track that's not really the
meat of it for me so to speak but we're
going to hopefully someday we will
ultimately know the truth I really
appreciate the call Ryan will continue
following it thanks David yep appreciate
it